tian bonjour mes très chers amis vous
l'avez reconnu mais oui c'est moi
fulbert en scène du snob peintre et
poète le plus grand créateur de
chefs-d'oeuvre de tout l'univers
mounard étant la rencontre de
l'expression de ma personnalité
exceptionnelle et l'impression suraigu
que mon regard transmet à ma main droite
vous n'avez rien compris ça ne fait rien
écouté bon alors en attendant de
commencer mon petit chef-d'oeuvre je
vais chercher une place pour installer
mon chevalet
maintien je crois que j'ai trouvé
ça se comprend tiens il semble que j'ai
reçu une goutte de nos jeunes et c'est
pas possible il faut qu'aujourd'hui non
julie soit gentil avant soit jeu jade de
pause expliqué en tue c'est françois qui
a vraiment été gentil de m'aider parce
que sans toi j'aurais fait je ne sais
combien d'allers retours havas annonce
je suis quelque chose tu vois mais il ya
quelqu'un là haut mais wiwa monsieur yao
des sondés immédiatement cet endroit est
réservé aux enfants de l'île allez hop
mais il semblerait que trop sage et nous
reconnaissent pas non plus ouais j'ai
pourtant une allure splendide
messieurs c'est le meilleur endroit pour
faire les plus beaux tableaux du monde
odom allez allez excusez moi monsieur
mais c'est impossible et pourquoi
mademoiselle cela serait impossible
et bien parce que les plus beaux
tableaux de sont faits par notre ami
monsieur le slovan la julie tu exagère
un peu bon allez monsieur maintenant
c'est fini vous vous descendez
immédiatement et vous trouver un endroit
où vous voulez et vous continuez votre
fille gribouillages mais pas là où c'est
interdit a les genoux tout tissu est
furieux flatté et orange et je leur
montrais que je suis
[Musique]
regardez moi ces idiots qui transporte
du bois par une chaleur pareille
là il fait tellement chaud que je suis
en âge moi je ne tiens plus en place
j'ai mal à ma carapace n'y a vraiment
plus de saison vous avez raison martin
il va pleuvoir
j'avais bien prévu je l'avais bien dit
[Musique]
il pleut il mouille lieu salle est
remplie ça va les gars vous c'est bon
pour les grenouilles et on risque tout
en lui brisant nous tant pis pour les
tango
[Musique]
on est donc il fallait il ne chante même
pas juste
à aa
[Musique]
la pluie a cessé
l'important dans la vie c'est de savoir
s'adapter wallon mais très bien bien
qu'on va la place dumesnil
il est trop beau chanteuse et strasbourg
en s'en allant bientôt du comté les
jeunots oublier que l'hiver au mobilier
qui
[Musique]
m
j'ai chassé le lézard vert pendant trois
jours au concours j'ai jouer à saute
pingouins avec un chef estime au jeu
suit restos chaque jour je colle un gros
oeuf d'autruche à mon petit déjeuner
j'ai chanté un opéra dans la rue à
tombouctou trouver les trésors cas dans
un musée du pétrole les gens s'arrachent
mais autographes au maroc au lieu dans
une rue quartier je
suis un champion de la sculpture
[Musique]
je
fait les chevreuse en peinture je suis
le plus grand le plus beau le plus fort
je connais le fils du frère de ma belle
soeur de marquis c'est un homme de
qualité la preuve ce qui me l'a dit
29 comment il colle un gros ap d'autres
chats son petit déjeuner
il sait parler chez très snob avec un
accent anglais
moi j'y arrive mieux avec la sam à payer
j'ai lu talent c'est évident de toute ma
rue je suis la célébrité jeu
suis un champion de la sculpture
[Musique]
pour eux
je
peu de chefs d'oeuvre en peinture je
suis le plus grand le plus beau le plus
fort mais il m'arrive quelquefois deux
frères un rêve un peu fou je m'appelle
monsieur durand et j'ai les mêmes eaux
que
jeanne supplice meurt alors je colle un
petit oeuf de poule qui me rend tous des
primaires
matin quand je m'éveille j'oublie mon
rêve et c'est bien je vois ma canne mon
chapeau et mon costume italien
ch redevient snow à leur jeu comme un
gros oeuf d'autruche à mon p'tit déj
[Musique]
salut françois tient bien je viens de
lire le nouveau numéro du journal de
l'île et à tout va bien il n'y a pas le
rajout revue monsieur bush elle vient de
recevoir une nouvelle auto encore plus
belle a fait et mademoiselle futin a
gagné le concours de feuilles darmon est
correct mais sa terrasse en tout ca du
break oui mais françois je ne voudrais
pas paraître idiot mais il y a une
nouvelle que je n'ai pas compris
laquelle donne jamais que c'est écrit là
roman regarde ce journal a été tiré à
200 exemplaires 1 est une sais pas ce
que ça veut dire tirez un journal à
plusieurs exemplaires moi j'en ai tiré
un derrière moi je ne vois pas l'intérêt
alors en tirer 200 kg mieux ça ne veut
pas dire traîner son journal derrière
soi enfin que
moi je crois que les enchante ça ce que
ça veut dire tu iras journal à plusieurs
exemplaires les enfants est-ce que ça
veut dire
oui dans une imprimerie quand on imprime
un journal d'abord aux fans une page
reprend des lettres les mais les unes
derrière les autres pour faire les mots
les phrases on met des photos des
dessins éventuellement on fait une
première épreuve et si cette première
épreuve est bonne eh bien on la tire à
de nombreux exemplaires ah ça vous
diront l'imprimerie voilà quasiment gang
sehili à d'autres procédés de
reproductions graphiques ya le bâti
carbone vous devez connaître le bâti
carbone les enfants quand voulais écrire
une lettre en plusieurs exemplaires on
est plusieurs feuilles de papier
blanches vous intercalé les feuilles de
carbone vous écrivez sur la première et
vous reproduisez ainsi cette lettre à
plusieurs exemplaires dans les bureaux
de poste casimir dans les bureaux de
poste de vue il ya des tampons les
tampons en caoutchouc y en a d'autres
aussi en métal on met deux langues ce
tampon et hop on produit plusieurs fois
qu' à ce qu'il brûle chez casimir il ya
aussi beaucoup d'autres procédés de
reproductions de gravures
oui eh bien moi je connais à un autre
procédé tout à fait différent l autre
procédé qui permet de reproduire un
tableau en deux exemples un tableau en
deux exemplaires vie mais je sois pas
lequel et bien je vous le dirai quand on
sera le moment où alors
ce mot demande que monsieur du snav est
en train de peindre il n'a pas arrêté de
tout l'après midi en tout cas ne va pas
déranger il a horreur de ça que j'avais
juste passé derrière lui tranquillement
non mais il ne s'apercevra même pas de
ma présence tu connais ma discrétion
julie ne t'en fais pas
d'égalé dignité
vous est pas possible je ne bouge pas
c'est vous qui m'avez bousculait qui le
portent des sacs et demi au foot et
l'équipe vétérans reverser mon chevalet
faveau
c'est presque terminé heureusement plus
qu'à signer
voilà la jeune yvonne et voit
encore monsieur diop est ce que je
pourrais l'avoir pour le mettre dans mon
cas ça que tu as raison je dis c'est
vraiment formidable
non moi j'aimerais beaucoup avoir pour
le maître chez moi au dessus de la malle
de léonard
enfin jusqu'à se disputer mon oeuvre
d'art mais quel réconfort pour le quart
de nartelle clown eh bien c'est dit je
le prends et je vous remercie de votre
non non non non rassurez moi laminaire
tout c'est moi qui ai droit et pour moi
parfois que c'est le poisson je vais
écouter écouter je ne sais vraiment pas
quoi comment trancher votre querelles ou
ailleurs je sais je et je vais
l'emporter chez moi
non alors 6e casimir le moment est venu
de vous montrer ma nouvelle technique
bon monsieur du snob a fait un
chef-d'oeuvre à julie souhaite la voir
moi aussi
voici donc un moyen
de faire
magnifique chef-d'oeuvre en deux
exemplaires
grâce à mon procès d unica voici donc
ce tableau
tiré à deux exemplaires
15 et murs
[Musique]